[Música]
en primera plana
carlos
[Música]
bienvenidos en primera plana un programa
de radio france internacional y de
france 24 esta semana ponemos el foco en
la figura de vladímir putin quizá la que
más de la que más hablamos en la
actualidad para ello me acompañan en
este estudio usé bioval corresponsal del
diario la vanguardia en francia
bienvenido
rafael cañas delegado de la agencia de
fe en francia bienvenido gracias carlos
fernando avakian experto en el espacio
ex soviético bienvenido fernando en
lieja tus y a distancia en dúplex anna
kowalczyk internacionalista de la
universidad de chile- bienvenida a na
buenos días gracias por la invitación
radiografía putin el autócrata que tiene
en jaque al mundo hoy en primera plana
[Música]
se cumple meses de la invasión rusa de
un cráneo como ya acuña a muchos
mandatarios de la guerra de putin
durante las últimas semanas en este
programa nos hemos centrado en la guerra
y en sus consecuencias a todos los
niveles y hoy nos centramos en la
persona en el en putin hombre
autoritario gran estratega geopolítico
manipulador mediático con imagen
prototípica de virilidad y de aprecio
por valores morales tradicionales de la
nación rusa con una determinación clara
por recuperar un peso internacional para
su país que quizás ha ido creciendo de
manera desbocada al sentirse humillado
la de putin es una batalla ideológica o
tiene poco de ello cuánto de personal
tiene la guerra de ucrania son algunas
de las preguntas que nos hacemos antes
de ello repasemos algunas portadas
juegan internacional en la cabeza de
putin un ejercicio que vamos a intentar
hacer hoy en el programa dice la
publicación que el mandatario ruso busca
todo precio mantener sus fuera de
influencia liberación con otro de sus
juegos de palabras putin de mal en peor
pero así escrito juega con esa
terminología del mal imperio contundente
la revista 'time' con esta portada el
retorno de la historia como putin ha
hecho polvo los sueños de europa
empezar a mis invitados un ejercicio si
tuvieran que definir a putin con unos
pocos calificativos en una ronda rápida
con dos o tres trazos cómo lo definiría
ya que es un autócrata al que el
ejercicio tan prolongado del poder ha
hecho perder racionalidad no se le creía
un individuo calculador y racional pero
después de más de 20 años da la
sensación de que ha perdido la
racionalidad en su conducta rafael yo
creo que es un hombre que que quedó
marcado por la desaparición de la unión
soviética y lo que percibió como
humillación de rusia en los años 90 y
que está realmente
imbuido de una especie de deber de
recuperar el
poderío y el prestigio perdido por rusia
fernando yo lo veo más bien como un como
un hijo sano como un producto del
discurso nacionalista presente en todas
las instancias formadoras de las élites
rusas principalmente el café de hoy el
facebook y el incremento en el éxito
internacionalista de la universidad de
chile porque es imposible disociar la
trayectoria de putin de la construcción
de la rusia postsoviética
en los órganos estatales de unión de
rusia postsoviética desde los inicios
putin tenía un cargo muy importante en
la ciudad de san petersburgo la alcaldía
donde fue prácticamente vice alcalde
tenía un puesto muy alto y donde se
dedicó prácticamente a defraudar a la
ciudad en conjunto con el alcalde no le
controlaban los puertos vendían las
propiedades estatales a empresas
internacionales a banca internacional a
muy bajo costo el programa tetuán tocó
hoy más también el proceso
en conjunto e hicieron negocios con
vivienda pública también se
enriquecieron muchísimo entonces en ese
sentido putin es como símbolo de
esta de esos nuevos líderes de rusia
post soviética que durante pocos años
cuando toda la sociedad está sufriendo
desempleo hambre y tetra se
enriquecieron muchísimo lo queremos al
pasado para entender al personaje a su
biografía pero mirándolo factual a putt
y le está saliendo bien esta guerra o es
una huida hacia adelante lo que estamos
viendo
donde donde intenta salir de este lío
con las botas puestas
es evidente que el cálculo ha sido
erróneo cálculo erróneo y el cálculo ha
sido erróneo ha sido ya desde el punto
de vista de cantidad de ejércitos
150.000 hombres para ocupar un país de
44 millones de habitantes tan grande
como francia o sea eso lo que sorprende
no es decir eso es una aventura
desmesurada para la capacidad capacidad
militar real a no ser que se dedica a
destruir por completo el país ese es
desde el punto de vista
ha sido un cálculo fallido desde el
inicio rafael sí
da la impresión que que en la operación
militar rusa
preveía una una guerra relámpago porque
no habría oposición ucraniana y se
encontraron todo lo contrario y también
creo que lo que no percibían había un
fallo de cálculo de que la reacción
extranjera sobre todo la europea que es
europa es quien depende de la energía
rusa iba a ser tan fuerte y tan rápida
llegados a este punto que sería para
putin una victoria en esta guerra o
dicho transforma cómo podría presentar
esto ante la opinión pública rusa como
una victoria fernando decías un suv
siempre que hay que dejar al enemigo un
puente de oro para para que se retirara
y que no lo viera como una especie de
inmigración declaró de humillación en el
caso de putin algo va a tener que vender
para con su para con su gente para con
rusia
una de las posibilidades por más de que
resulte terrorífico pensarlo así sería
una partición de ucrania según la cual
una parte quede bajo un gobierno adicto
a moscú una especie como de lukashenko
como es el caso en bielorrusia
posiblemente teniendo como capital hard
kit que había sido en su época la
capital de la ucrania soviética
y presentando esto como una victoria
siempre y cuando no llegue a tomar 10
que es todavía una posibilidad el serbio
dónde está esa salida como pero creo que
occidente pueda
aceptar ese desenlace porque sería
premiar una agresión
injustificada yo creo que
hay que darle un máximo porque ya lo
está ofreciendo excelentes que sería la
neutralidad de ucrania
aceptar que crimea sigue se mantiene
como dentro de rusia
creo que occidente y la propia ucrania
lo máximo que puede aceptar y es mucho
es una neutralidad con garantías reales
pero eso es va a ser muy difícil de
negociar yo creo que ahí está el meollo
de la salida en este momento si eso es
una salida no humillante o no para putin
es dudoso rafael
yo coincido con eusebio tal vez
que quería aceptar a la
y la aquí la comunidad internacional la
anexión de crimea o incluso de las
partes ahora controladas por rusia en
las
regiones de donges y lugansk porque
además hay que están public pobladas por
russo fornos y aparentemente ruso filos
tal vez incluso a ucrania no le interesa
recuperar el control para no tener
digamos el enemigo dentro pero está la
cuestión de ver si eso sería suficiente
para rusia después de
semejante gasto tanto en recursos
militares como en
imagen de rusia destruida en el exterior
bueno estos días estamos revisando la
biografía de putin al detalle fernando
cuál es el error más frecuente que
hacemos al analizar el personaje en mi
opinión el error más frecuente sería ver
en putin un personaje aislado es decir
no verlo como como decía poco poco antes
como un producto de un discurso casi que
omnipresente en las altas esferas del
poder en moscú es decir putin está
animado por una cierta revisión
histórica de la propia historia rusa que
no es propia del mismo y que lleva mucho
tiempo digamos en la
en la escena pública rusa
putin él mismo escribió él en julio del
2021 un ensayo que él mismo también
publicó en la página del gobierno ruso
en la cual explica un poco su visión de
lo que es la historia rusa en la cual
habla acerca de la unidad de ucrania y
de rusia la cual dice el pueblo
ucraniano es parte del pueblo ruso
cuidado todos los nacionalismos se
parecen en el hecho de que todos ellos
se creen únicos y en este sentido
obviamente conocemos el excepcional
mismo estadounidense conocemos el
proyecto civilizatorio chino lo de
russian es algo único pero en gran
medida
resulta mucho más en este momento mucho
más agresivo que otros tipos de
nacionalismos y yo creo que esto es lo
que anima en última instancia a putin
rafa eusebio que errores hemos cometido
a la hora de analizar el personaje
esto de que no es un fenómeno personal
quizás producto de un desequilibrio o no
que hay que ahí hay toda la estructura
de pensamiento
detrás y que la caída de los imperios
siempre es muy problemática
yo creo que occidente quizás ha cometido
también el error durante estos años del
2014 hasta ahora de no haber ofrecido a
rusia este estatuto de neutralidad
ucrania ir e insistiendo hasta el último
momento las puertas de la otan están
abiertas las puertas del es claro no
habría que darle excusas ninguna excusa
a putin y yo creo que es intolerable e
injustificable lo que ha hecho putin
pero occidente es en estos años no no
tenía una política inteligente para
prevenirlo lanza la misma pregunta en
acabar desde chile cuál es el error que
más frecuente hemos hecho a la hora de
analizar a putin sobre todo útil parece
ser analizado como un personaje racional
y porque se lo considera nacional será
considerado nacional porque le interesan
intereses económicos sobre todo no
podrían ha tenido muy buenas relaciones
con las empresas europeas italianas
alemanas no he hecho muchos negocios él
mismo es el hombre de negocios él
hizo que procter y ángulo por ejemplo
una empresa multinacional entró al
mercado ruso es decir creó una empresa
que sirvió como un joint venture para
procter gamble en rusia entonces hay una
tendencia que parece ser con tendencia
de nuestros tiempos de creer que las
personas que se enfocan en enriquecerse
en su interés privado son en cierto modo
contrarios a cursos de personaje son
compuestos del culto de personaje donde
autoritarismo etcétera entonces yo creo
que hay una tendencia de enfocarse
solamente en este
este
enfoque de intereses privados como que
moderan nosotras las otras pasiones
rafael y ahí yo creo que hay dos y no
sólo uno uno es
no tener
o no tomar en serio
a putin y los avisos que va lanzando una
de las grandes analistas de putin
dijo recientemente putin hace lo que
dice que va a hacer
entonces igual en occidente no se ha
tomado en serio se pensaban que eran
bravuconadas que eran faroles de poker
y no pensaban que podía ser cierto y el
otro error es hay mucha gente que está
pensando que tal vez putin no está en
sus cabales
y hasta en los medios de comunicación
internacionales han recurrido a
psicólogos o psiquiatras que insisten el
hecho de que no entendamos el marco
mental de una persona no significa que
esté loco ni que esté a la cabeza sino
que funciona de otra forma ahora pido la
palabra fernando hace lo que hacemos en
este punto una breve pausa enseguida
volvemos en primera plana esta hora
[Música]
france24 la economía día a día
liberté égalité
actualidad
reporteros el programa de reportajes de
france 24 descubra las historias de la
gente con nuestros reporteros por todo
el planeta
nuestros periodistas van donde ocurre la
noticia para contársela cada semana
reporteros le trae una historia inédita
no se la pierda
reporteros en france 24 y france 24
puntocom
seguimos en primera plana esta semana
analizando la figura de putin con
eusebio va al corresponsal de la
vanguardia rafael cañas delegado de la
agencia efe en parís fernando avakian
experto en el espacio ex soviético y en
dúplex anaco vancsik internacionalista
de la universidad de chile antes de
irnos a la pausa estábamos hablando de
los errores de análisis que hemos podido
cometer analizando la figura de putin
fernando y algo entre es importante de
recalcar es que desde occidente tenemos
muchas veces a olvidar el factor interno
es decir los motores internos de la
expansión rusa es decir la grilla de
lectura según la cual la expansión de la
otan podría simplemente explicar por sí
misma la agresividad rusa termina siendo
insuficiente tenemos que entender a
rusia como un procés como como un polo
civilizatorio es decir como una
civilización y no como un país y en ese
sentido cuando uno habla de rusia por lo
general habla de las fronteras actuales
de la federación rusa cuando desde el
punto de vista del kremlin se habla
siempre de lo que ellos mismos dicen el
russkiy mir es decir el el mundo que no
necesariamente coincide con las
fronteras cambiantes de la federación de
rusia entonces cuando uno se plantea
porque avanza el kremlin ante europa
oriental y en realidad no necesariamente
esto obedece a una expansión de la otan
aunque sí sin duda eso implica en alguna
medida como la necesidad de actuar por
parte del kremlin pero esta visión
patrimonialista para con el resto de los
pueblos eslavos y de europa oriental en
general precede a la existencia de la
otan y está en la génesis misma del
estado ruso de la creación del estado
ruso vamos a hacer un breve repaso a la
biografía los puntos fundamentales de la
historia que han marcado a putin
anna kowalczyk se oye y se lee mucho de
que los años de la carrera y luego su
paso por el fsb el servicio federal de
seguridad han sido determinantes para el
recorrido de putin y la concepción que
tiene de la de la rusa que por que está
construyendo que tan cierto es pero
seguramente el paso de plugin por canje
vez contribuyó a fortalecer su
mentalidad
como llena de sospecha de mentiras de
juegos con estándares dobles etcétera no
los métodos que está usando hasta ahora
también en cajeme putin estaba encargado
de trabajar con la disidencia le vendría
demandar la disidencia a la cárcel no
buscar pruebas
seguir a estudiar los los bebés no la
vida de esas personas y además también
putin trabajaba encaje ven dresde aunque
fuera alemania oriental
donde él vio la caída de la unión
soviética la caída del muro de berlín
andrés tan
él lo vivió y seguramente fue un choque
también ahí para él él estaba en berlín
cuando las multitudes
alemanas que
reclamaban
transformaciones en alemania oriental se
fueron hacia la sede de la calle ver
hacia la sede de la policía secreta
alemana estás
protestando contra ellos entonces parece
que también está sensación de la
decadencia de la unión soviética que él
vio de primera mano también lo ha
impactado muchísimo quizá la pregunta
sea un serbio su megalomanía y su
ascenso autoritario se han ido
desarrollando más con el paso del tiempo
esto me recuerda por ejemplo a erdogán o
esa determinación sin resistido desde el
principio como sido construyendo como
creen que se ha ido construyendo esa
yo creo que se ha ido construyendo y es
que yo creo que uno de los elementos del
análisis es el carácter autoritario del
régimen este tipo de sistemas necesita
está este expansionismo esta necesidad
de generarse enemigos internos y
externos yo creo que esto es una de las
claves para entender sobrevivir gracias
a ello claro y es no dejar ser
raro que rusia a pesar de todo
durante los últimos 20 años ha tenido un
desarrollo económico ha generado
bienestar no para todo el mundo pero
comparado con los años 90
del siglo pasado después de la que el
comunismo es decir ha generado el nivel
de vida ha aumentado mucho
y ha demostrado una cosa que también que
una dictadura un régimen autocrático
puede generar bienestar material
y en cambio esto se lo está cargando de
la cuerda manera con esta invasión no
está poniendo en riesgo porque lo que es
es difícil de entender este paso de
todos los episodios de la biografía de
putin muchos analistas otorgan un valor
especial al agresivo discurso de putin
en la conferencia de múnich de 2007 en
su intervención
putin condenó firmemente los esfuerzos
de eeuu por construir un mundo unipolar
y criticó el acercamiento de la otan
hacia las fronteras de rusia cuántas
veces hemos rescatado estos días y
rafael fernando aquel discurso y muchas
muchas de todas formas
esto se refiere a lo que ya decía hace
un momento de qué
releyendo los discursos de putin 1p que
todas sus
sus temas
su puestas
quejas acerca del trato que daba en eeuu
y sus aliados a rusia vienen muy de
largo y tal vez no hayan sido
suficientemente
tenidas en cuenta de todas formas
también es cierto que que los países de
la antigua órbita soviética que entraron
en la otan sean las repúblicas bálticas
que sí eran parte de la unión soviética
sean países del antiguo pacto de
varsovia como polonia la antigua
checoslovaquia o rumanía
apenas hay tropas de la otan
prácticamente no hay tropas de la otan
ahí no hay una
concentración de fuerzas de misiles del
armamento que pueda amenazar a
a rusia desde ahí entonces parte de esa
retórica es un poco falsa otro punto de
la biografía seguimos repasando con
imágenes las ofensivas militares para
asegurar la influencia del kremlin no
son una táctica aislada en los 22 años
de vladimir putin al frente de rusia
primero fue chechenia que coincidió con
su ascenso al poder y fue ahí donde se
consolidó quizás su imagen de hombre
fuerte de cara a los rusos fernando en
chechenia yo reforme un la día diciendo
que fue chechenia fue la segunda guerra
de chechenia convulso lo que propuso a
putin al poder y estamos hablando del 94
en 1999 90999 cuando putin es primer
ministro y luego pasa a ser presidente
fue a través de
la imagen del enemigo checheno que
encarnaba cierto ideal del terror isla
del terrorista islamista que atacaba a
rusia lo que propulsó a putin al poder
primero de un poder formal y segundo a
la popularidad
porque es muy interesante ver que hay
hay muchos parangones con la retórica
que se utiliza hoy tierra de ucrania con
la segunda guerra de chechenia
putin utiliza siempre términos
imaginarios que están fuertemente
anclados en la población rusa en su
época fue hablar del enemigo terrorista
islamista que está atacando a través de
diversos atentados en las ciudades rusas
en caso de ucrania utiliza una técnica
similar que simplemente decir son los
nazis recuerden los nazis que nosotros
hemos vencido en el segunda guerra
mundial que reaparecen en ucrania
entonces que no queremos desmilitarizar
desclasificar entonces nuevamente son
discursos que están bien arraigados en
la población rusa y que les resulta
extremadamente útil es otro momento
porque putin impulsó su mano de hierro
una década después en georgia en 2008 ya
nuclear en 2014 pero por primera vez
justo antes de ello putin se dio un gran
baño de masas en shock si los recordamos
fueron los llamados juegos de invierno
de putin para muchos analistas aquellos
faustos fueron como una especie de
ceremonia de coronación del zar fai en
sochi donde putin mostró al mundo la
gran vitrina de su poder y de sus
ambiciones
recuerdan esos faustos forman parte de
esto y por eso yo insistiría en decir
que está dilapidando
dilapidando s
esa estatura que había conseguido atrás
como interlocutor en medio oriente había
concluirse se le estaba perdonando esa
cosa a esas muy graves esa gaseosa nato
de periodistas
su brutalidad en chechenia se le están
perdonando muchas cosas y ahora
está arriesgando lo está arriesgando
todo por esa arrogancia que da el poder
absoluto durante tantos años yo creo que
es un caso típico de rafael s como decía
eusebio voy a decir ha pillado ese gran
capital que había conseguido como
interlocutor además en oriente medio de
muchos sitios de sí desde luego
la imagen de putin en
occidente está actualmente destruida
fernando es importante en recalcar lo
siguiente justamente putin
quiere una vez más ser la imagen del
líder de los pueblos eslavos y en ese
sentido está ganando cada vez más
popularidad en rusia aunque esto es muy
difícil de verificar claro eso es otra
pero por otro lado posiblemente si esta
jugada le sale bien en alguna medida
esto va a generar apoyo en el resto del
mundo eslavo como por ejemplo los
serbios que no saben qué hacer dónde
posicionarse entre europa y rusia no
sabe que no se sabe qué va a ocurrir en
bielorrusia luego de el fin de la guerra
que no sabemos qué va a pasar
rafa
efectivamente la imagen de putin en
digamos en occidente del occidente
tradicional está absolutamente hundida
ahora pero sí me gustaría recalcar que
a nivel de
otros países no tanto y no tanto igual
por amor a rusia como por contra persa
estados un contrapeso a eeuu es decir
los los brics de china india suráfrica
brasil no están siendo críticos con
rusia el otro nivel el gobierno mexicano
está manteniendo una posición muy
prudente para no criticar a rusia y en
ese sentido fuera de lo que es europa
occidental eeuu canadá australia
o japón lo que llamamos también oriente
si está manteniendo distancias aunque
china parece que está contemporizando
mucho la postura porque es el menos
interesado china no le gusta nada parece
lo que está pasando fernando me parece
interesante recalcar lo siguiente y esto
estuvimos hablando justamente antes de
salir en cámara es importante recalcar
que criticar o denunciar la acción de
putin en ucrania no significa
tácitamente apoyar ni el actuar ni la
existencia misma de la otan y esto me
parece que es algo que termina
empobreciendo el debate esta visión de
mujer así esta visión un poco maniquea
dicotómica de si tratar la geopolítica
como el footsie sí o sí es horrible y me
parece que esto importante recalcarlo
porque en pobre es el debate bueno me
quedo sin problemas con una frase de
sujeto verbo y predicado rafa esto
siente un poco la invasión rusa de
ucrania
y ha cambiado para muchas décadas la
vida en europa y las consecuencias que
nos va a traer muchísimas gracias a los
cuatro ya todos ustedes hasta la próxima
semana en primera plana gracias
[Música]